you
so I have known before I started writing
this book I had known about many of
these accidental scientific scientific
discoveries and I had learned about them
in some level of degree some some degree
of detail but I had not I had not really
looked at them kind of analytically out
of what makes this possible so once I
had this book and was writing it and I
began to collect a few more of these
anecdotes and look at them in more
detail and gather sometimes people's lab
books or papers that were published
reminiscences that happened many years
after the fact when I got those and put
those together I realized that there
were three elements that had to be part
of every accidental scientific discovery
the first is preparation many people
have seen evidence that scientists later
on said oh wow this is something cool
they saw it but because they were not
prepared to recognize there was
something unusual and what they had seen
they just didn't pay any attention to it
the other is the actual circumstance
itself whatever the accident is and I
call that opportunity so the opportunity
needs to be there to create or make an
observation create something that you
observe or just observe something in
nature observe a natural effect and the
third element is desire once you see you
know what you're doing you know what to
expect something unusual happens you're
in this circumstances something unusual
has happened now it's very easy in many
different environments to just toss that
aside and say alright well that was
interesting
and just move on with your work just
scientists are just like everybody else
I've got a job to do you know they're
investigating they may be investigating
how to build how to create a new dye for
clothes and it won't necessarily occur
to them to look at that dye and see if
it can be used to cure disease so when
you see an effect like that you can't
just say oh that's not my job I am
working on making a dye you have to have
the desire to follow up the accidental
observation you of
so just about everyone has heard of
Louis Pasteur Louis Pasteur is
interesting because he is in one very
major sense the father of vaccinations
now he actually did not do the first
vaccine but he was the first one who
created a vaccine where they had some
idea about why things might be working
so he starts to create this this
scenario which ends up being the
framework for all modern medicine really
and Louis Pasteur had a very
controversial theory and that was that
diseases were caused by microorganisms
so chicken cholera cholera was a very
and still is when it occurs a very
debilitating and dangerous disease and
it was also very economically important
for agriculture chicken cholera was
killing a significant percentage of the
poultry in France and Pasteur said I
believe this is due to this infectious
agent so he pulled this infectious agent
out what he believed to be the
infectious agent he pulled that
infectious agent out and put it in both
he would make like a soup and you he
would grow the microorganism by feeding
him like chicken soup really and then he
would take some of that broth and he
would eject it into the chickens and
when he took that broth and inject it
into the chickens they died now to
Pasteur this was kind of proof that this
this organism was causing the disease
but people were not all that easily
convinced of the strengths of his
occupation at that time and so he had to
do this over and over and over again
well he's doing this for a long time and
it's time for summer vacation so he
leaves and he leaves his assistants he
says alright you guys I've got this
batch of infectious agent here you know
three days from now go ahead and inject
all these chickens
so pasture is gone he's on vacation and
just like a lot of employees do when the
boss is gone they put their feet up it
should have their thumbs and say you
know it's time for my vacation - they
took off his assistants took off without
injecting this broth that came back two
weeks later
the broth is there pastor says what did
you do this for I'm you know how hard it
is to make these brawls and get these
things I wish you would have injected
these chickens ahead of time the guy
said well sorry but I can do it now he
said alright do it now so he injected
all the chickens with this the broth
that was now two and a half weeks old
and none of them died they got sick but
none of them died and Pasteur said gosh
darn it look he ruined the broth make
them make a new batch now and this time
you got to make twice as much because
now we got we were behind schedule so we
got to infect a lot more chickens so I
made a new batch of the broth and they
infected a whole bunch of chickens some
of the ones that had already been
injected with the the old broth and some
that were not injected with also every
chicken that was not eat earlier
injected with the old broth died every
single chicken that had already been
injected with the old broth lived and
Pasteur said whoa let's do this again
and he repeated the experiment and now
it turns out that Pasteur had the wrong
idea for why his injection was working
now we know that when the body detects
an infectious agent it begins to
manufacture weapons against that
infectious agent now normally or many
times if the infectious infectious agent
is deadly your body's response to that
agent is slower than the agent can work
and you get either really sick or you
die
but if you slow down that infectious
agent if you weaken it ahead of time so
that it's slower it can't not as healthy
I can't fight back as well against your
body's defenses then your body's
defenses can get ahead and now the next
time that you get that infectious agent
your body's all prepared so what you do
is you inject someone with a weakened
portion of weakened portion of that
infectious agent nowadays we have
fancier ways of doing it too but a
weakened
version of that infectious agent your
body gets used to it and when the real
thing comes along you're all set your
body says hey I'm ready for you you're
gone so that's and it was all because of
that accidental discovery of that
wouldn't have happened if he hadn't
taken a summer vacation so the story of
Louis Pasteur and his accidental
discovery is it's a very interesting one
and certainly has ramifications for the
modern world but one of the interesting
things about accidental discovery is
that the person who makes this
observation they need to be able to
pursue that observation to its logical
end for Pasteur it's easy he was the
boss he had two guys working for him
whatever he said when so when he wanted
to look at something they just looked at
it it's a lot tougher in the corporate
world and not only today but in 1938 for
example so in 1938 there was a chemist
called Roy Plunkett who was working for
DuPont and his job was to make new
refrigerants so things like free on the
the CFCs and they had a process of doing
it they there were some there was some
well-defined chemistry for making new
things they would put certain elements
together and then kind of put them under
pressure maybe treat some with
temperature and then we're trying all
sorts of different things to get
something that would make a good
compound for working in refrigerants in
refrigerators and other motors and and
other kinds of compressors so that was
his job his job is to make a new
refrigerant well one day they left their
best to sit overnight they came the next
day and they opened up these big gas
bottles that they put they did their
reactions and he opened up the big gas
bottle and nothing comes out and he says
oh shoot the it must have leaked now
right there he could have said it must
have leaked he could have thrown that
bottle out and started over again but
instead of saying it's oh well what if
it didn't leak he said let's weigh this
bottle so we weighed the bottle and the
bottle way just as message as it should
have with all the things in it he said
all right wait a second
it didn't leak but there's no gas in
there so what the heck is going on so we
unscrewed the top of the thing and a
little bit of white powder kind of
looking like a shredded coconut was in
was in there anything what is this
so they actually saw the bottle in half
and pull it out and there is this white
powdery stuff kind of coating the
outside of this metal gas bottle now
recall his job is to make a gaseous
refrigerant that can be used that his
company DuPont can now go sell to make
money and in their refrigerators and
other things that require that kind of
capability but he went to his boss and
he said look at this this material is
really kind of cool I mean look at look
how slippery this stuff is and so he was
able to get the buy-in from his bosses
and he himself had the curiosity and and
the gumption to go say hey this looks
this thing looks really interesting what
it ends up that he made was Teflon now
Teflon nowadays we think of it most
commonly we think of it in terms of the
non-stick pans and even though we're
kind of a little bit moved beyond Teflon
in general but still Teflon was the
nonstick material but it's also many
other things it's in wire insulation and
and many other similar products but in
the 1930s particularly late night late
1930s there was another problem that was
happening the world was just kind of
discovering atomic energy and one of the
things that they discovered was that
they needed this uranium and uranium
comes in the form that's called uranium
hexafluoride and it's very toxic it's
very toxic it's very caustic it just it
eats through anything around well when
you have when you have a process where
you want to push this chemical through a
factory kind of operation when you want
to do that you've got to have seals
you've got to have valves you've got to
have joints and it's the rubber that you
make those things out of just
disintegrates as this stuff is going
through and it's talked
not really nasty stuff and it's
radioactive on top of that you don't
want that you need to have some kind of
material you can use to make a good feel
you can make Vow like bearings with it
it's a that's not exactly the right term
but you can have two surfaces that made
against each other and move and yet they
still maintain a good seal the Teflon is
so slippery and yet it's so resistant
chemically that it was it ended up being
the perfect answer for that problem
which was confronting the world right at
that time and the United States in
particular and once again this one is
interesting because Plunkett had the
preparation he was a chemist he knew
what he was looking for he knew what to
expect he knew when something strange
happened he had the opportunity he by
chance but it made the conditions just
right to make this new material but what
he could easily have not had was the
desire to follow it through he had a job
to do he had to ignore that job because
there was something that was really
interesting here and it wasn't just him
he had to then be interested enough that
he could go to his bosses and say hey
you know what this thing is really cool
we should take a look at this thing and
so preparation opportunity and desire
came through for him and that's why
there's Teflon in the world today so one
of the prototypical examples of
accidental discovery in the scientific
community is the discovery of x-rays the
x-rays were discovered in 1895 by vilho
moonkin in germany x-rays are still
known as renkin rays and to acknowledge
the seminal his seminal role in the
discovery and there was one of the
reasons why it's an interesting
discovery is because it makes it very
clear that you need a lot more just in
preparation and opportunity you need
that desire as well and this is why
around that time people scientists were
discovering the nature mannered matter
they were exploring the nature of matter
in the same way that we're exploring it
now but this was before they even had a
concept of the atom so the idea of a
nucleus and electrons surrounding it was
unknown as
however they did find a new state of
matter called cathode rays and you could
make a cathode ray by taking a glass
bowl like a lightbulb more or less and
putting a filament in it like a
lightbulb filament but putting it very
high voltage and it's a little more
complicated than that but that's the
general idea so you could take that and
then you could see this beam of
something and which was called cathode
ray because they had no idea what it was
now we know that those cathode rays are
electrons but at the time they had no
idea well there were many people were
investigating these cathode rays but it
turns out that something else was
happening as well in addition to this
this cathode ray there was another kind
of radiation that was coming from this
and vilain lankan saw a he had just put
some photographic plates down and he saw
that there was an outline of an object
on these photographic plates and he said
whoa that's not from the cathode rays
because cathode rays don't don't do that
they don't have this effect on this film
and so he said I will I'm going to take
a look and see what these things are so
we did all sorts of things so with a
cathode ray if you put cathode ray if
you put them in a magnetic field you put
a magnet and they'll Bend well he said
what would these things Bend
no they won't Bend well cathode rays
don't go through very much if you put
just like a piece of paper they're
absorbed they don't go beyond well they
go through a piece yes it will go
through a piece of paper he did a series
of experiments over six weeks that's
fully it it has been said that in six
weeks he learned everything that would
be known about x-rays for the next 100
years
so other things have been learned since
then but he did such an exhaustive
investigation of x-rays for that six
weeks he buried himself in those and
heat by the time he was done he had a
complete understanding of the operation
of x-rays now he didn't understand
everything and in this sense he was
lucky where people didn't realize what
he did not
at the time was that x-rays are what's
called ionizing radiation which means
when they hit living material or
nonliving material want to hit any
material they will knock off pieces of
it they'll kind of destroy it a little
bit and bit by bit just in tiny little
bits but over time it can add up and be
dangerous and so luckily for Rankin he
did all his experiments in a lead-lined
darkroom and so he did that to keep
light out what he didn't know was that
he was also protecting himself from the
dangerous effects of the x-rays over the
next couple decades people were exposed
to these x-rays and began to develop
lesions on their hands and other things
because of that but x-rays continue to
be used as a medically viable important
tool a very important for diagnostics
nowadays we learn methods to
significantly reduce the dose by making
the sensitivity of the detectors much
higher but without x-rays there are the
the whole science of medical imaging
would not be anywhere near where it is
today if it weren't for those six weeks
that one can spend digging into this and
one of the interesting things about it
of course it not only did did one can
get some degree of fame for this which
he did not really enjoy he does not like
the fact that in Germany they feel or he
did not like the fact that in Germany
they called them Renkin rays he wanted
him just to be x-rays but not only did
he get that Fame when he got that degree
of fame all these other folks come out
of the woodwork and say well I saw that
too and I thought and they had you can
look they written in their notebooks yes
we - and what did they do with it
nothing they just say they said oh that
was funny and they left it and so this
is one of the things that's difficult
for people who aren't in the scientific
field they say oh he was just lucky well
it can't be just lucky it takes a lot
more than that you've got to have the
preparation to see that something
unusual has happened you have to have
the opportunity to see that unusual
thing whatever it happens to be and
that's the chance part you have to and
part of that is directed by you know the
more you look at things the more you'll
see
but you need to also have that desire
and what people outside when they when
people outside scientific and
technological fields think of the role
of chance sometimes I think of it like
winning the lottery just going to win
the lottery and that's why you made the
scientific discovery no you cannot do it
unless you first put in all that
groundwork to be able to understand the
basics what should happen and when
something happens that shouldn't happen
you have to know enough to question it
and you have to have the desire to
follow it up and that's why the story of
x-rays is such an interesting one in the
scientific annals the more that we
prepare ourselves with a baseline of
knowledge for whatever it is we are
doing the easier it is for us to
identify when things are unusual and
once you are in a situation where you're
given the opportunity to see something
unusual
then you're now it's really in your it's
in your hands now you've prepared
yourself you worked hard you're trained
in whatever this thing happens to be you
had the chance observation or the the
hand of fate stepped in and show you
something
and now do you have the desire to follow
it up and it could be just something as
simple as you play a sport and something
happens and just accidentally you do
something you say oh whoa that really
worked and now you say well yeah but
that's not the way I'm supposed to do it
so or do you follow it up do you say
well I'm going to see if I can really
make this work and I think that happens
in we can apply those principles in many
different ways in our lives and enrich
ourselves by being open to following
those chance opportunities that present
themselves to us